principles for success an ultra
mini-series adventure in 30 minutes and
in eight episodes episode five
everything is a machine sometimes things
happen that are hard to understand life
often feels so difficult and complicated
it's too much to take in all at once my
deep pain led me to reflect deeply on my
circumstances it also led me to reflect
on nature because it provides a guide
for what's true so I thought a lot about
how things work which helped to put me
and my own circumstances in perspective
I saw that at the Big Bang all the laws
and forces of the universe were created
and propelled forward interacting with
each other as a perpetual motion machine
in which all the bits and pieces
coalesce into machines that work for a
while
fall apart and then coalesce into new
machines this goes on into eternity I
saw that everything is a machine the
structure and evolution of galaxies the
formation of our own solar system the
makeup of Earth's geography and
ecosystems our economies and markets and
each of us we individually are machines
made up of different machines our
circulatory system our nervous system
that produce our thoughts our dreams our
emotions and all the other aspects of
our distinct characters all of these
different machines evolve together
through time to produce the realities we
encounter every day and I realized that
I was just one tiny bit in one
nanosecond deciding what I should do
while that perspective might sound very
philosophical I found that it was very
practical because it showed me how I
could deal with my own realities in a
better way for example I observed that
most everything happens over and over
again in slightly different ways some in
obvious short-term cycles that are easy
to recognize so we know how to deal with
them
like the 24-hour day
some so infrequently that they haven't
occurred in our lifetimes and were
shocked when they do like the once in a
hundred year storm and some we know
exist but are encountering for the first
time like the birth of our first child
most people mistakenly treat these
situations as being unique and deal with
them without having proper perspective
or principles to help them get through
them I found that if instead of dealing
with these events as one-offs and I
could see each as just another one of
those and approach them in the same way
a biologist might approach an animal
first identifying its species then
drawing on principles for dealing with
it appropriately because I could see
these events transpire in pretty much
the same ways over and over I could more
clearly see the cause-effect
relationships that govern their
behaviors which allowed me to develop
better principles that I could express
in both words and algorithms I learned
that while most everyone expects the
future to be a slightly modified version
of the present it is typically very
different that's because people are
biased by recent history an overlooked
events that haven't happened in a long
time perhaps not even in their lifetime
but they will happen again with that
perspective I realized that what I
missed when I mistakenly called for a
Great Depression was hidden in the
patterns of history and I could use my
newfound knowledge of these patterns to
make better decisions in the future and
when I thought about my challenge
balancing risk and reward I realized
that risk and reward naturally go
together I could see that to get the
most out of life one has to take more
risk and that knowing how to
appropriately balance risk and reward is
essential to having the best life
possible imagine you are faced with the
choice of having a safe boring life if
you stay where you are or having a
fabulous one if you take the risk of
successfully crossing a dangerous jungle
that is essentially the choice we all
face for me the choice was clear but
that doesn't mean the path forward was
with
challenges I still needed to face two
big barriers that we all must face in
Episode six I'll share some invaluable
techniques I learned about how to best
do that
[Music]